hey guys it's the middle of the week I'm
Dan I'm Jeff and here's what happened in
gaming today first up here's the free
games you can get as part of your
PlayStation Plus and xbox live
subscription in October for all of your
PlayStation 4 owners out there you'll be
able to get your hands on the narrative
League discouraging but gameplay
encouraging Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain saying is it's the
spookiest month of the year you can also
grab the amnesia collection which
includes amnesia the Dark Descent and a
machine for pigs on ps3 you can shoot
some pool in hustle kings or play the
monster truck version of trials Monster
Jam battlegrounds October's - Vita games
Hugh and Sky Force anniversary are also
playable on ps4 via crossfire
now - Xbox as part of xbox live games
with Golder this month you can grab the
fantastic adventure game go on home come
October 16th you'll also be able to grab
the first-person puzzle adventure the
Turing test xbox 360 owners will be
getting Rayman 3 HD for the first half
of the month and medal of honor airborne
during the second half both of which are
playable on Xbox one via backwards
compatibility I don't know if you guys
spent a lot of time on in cata as a kid
but I did so the fact that Assassin's
Creed origins was getting an educational
no combat only discovery mode it's super
exciting to me nerd the so called
discovery tour is a casual mode coming
in 2018 as a free update that as Jess
said takes out all the combat so you can
just mosey around ancient Egypt you're
able to walk or ride through the
entirety of the game and explore
locations like Alexandria Memphis the
Nile Delta the Giza Plateau the fááá--
MO ASIS and the great sand seas there's
no story no combat and no time limits as
you'd imagine the entire point of this
mode is to help players understand and
experience the history of ancient Egypt
they will apparently be dozens of guided
tours that were organized by real
historians and experts which cover
things like the great pyramids the
mummification process and Cleopatra's
life basically this sounds amazing and
I'm super excited to see a big games
company include something like this well
tonight's a survival game that is going
to be free-to-play but currently isn't
just introduced it's free battle really
an old boy is off to a strong start
after drawing similarities to play our
knowns battlegrounds and the ire of its
developer blue hole the free mode
fortnight Battle Royale launched
yesterday on ps4 Xbox one and PC and
according to Epic Games more than 1
million players have jumped from the
legally distinct but also similar to bus
planes and hunted each other across an
island I guess that really goes to show
how hungry console players are for a
battle royale mode this isn't the only
free stuff epic has planned for
fortnight they also plan to release the
save the world PvE campaign for free
sometime next year this is a forum I
just found it on the floor in our set I
don't know what that means but I think
it means that we're done for today but
we'll be here tomorrow and then Friday
for the top 5 news stories of the entire
week so we'll see you guys there I'm
swag ready to give you guys some games
what news I'm down by the way Jeff
good job notice of high-fiving here I
have I'm very aggressively so I'm sorry
about that
hey hey guys